all right so Apple's Wonder list event
happened it was uh it was pretty
interesting honestly not that much stuff
actually got announced I mean we knew it
was going to be iPhone Apple watch USBC
not that much other stuff but it was it
was more the stuff in between the lines
that was kind of interesting and some
other random stuff that I don't think a
lot of people are talking about so let's
talk about it now first of all I got to
say it was a complete surprise to me
when one of the first things that they
did was quote my MacBook Air review so
you know like the beginning of the
Keynotes they usually do where they sort
of recap a bunch of stuff that's
previously happened one of the things
they did was talk about the MacBook Air
and this happened and Mark has brownly
said the 15-in MacBook Air is going to
instantly rock it to the top of the
lineup to become the most popular 15in
laptop we love the new Macbook Air and
the entire Mac
lineup and that was pretty cool I got to
say they didn't tell me they were going
to do that they didn't ask they didn't
pay for it they just kind of did it so
so shout out to Tim I guess in this case
it's totally fine I guess there's just
an element of Pride knowing that like
it's come a long way since the beginning
I remember like six seven eight years
ago when there were zero YouTubers at
any of these events and then there was
one and then there were three or four
and then there were 12 or 13 and just
now we're all just a part of the media
independent creators doing our thing so
I feel like it's kind of a cool moment
to see that come full circle but anyway
after that they just got right into the
announcements the flagship of which
being the new iPhone so I made an entire
separate video on the iPhones my first
Hands-On and impressions of all the
little details and my first thoughts of
everything so I'll link that below the
like button if you want to check it out
if you're interested but I'll just do a
brief summary here for you so the iPhone
15 gets the a16 bionic chip from last
year's iPhone Pro it gets the dynamic
island of course from the pro as well
some new colors and a slightly updated
design with a little better curve
radiuses radi slightly nicer feel on the
hand and a satin soft touch back and a a
slow USBC Port same starting price and
screen sizes as last year $7.99 for the
iPhone 15 and $8.99 for the iPhone 15
plus so then the iPhone 15 Pro gets a
new 3 NM a17 Pro chip there's these new
brush lighter titanium rails to replace
a stainless steel a faster USBC port a
customizable action button on the side
to replace the mute switch a new set of
cameras and just the 15 Pro Max gets a
new 5x telephoto camera and the prices
are kind of sneaky so it's still $9.99
for the 15 Pro but the pro Max now
starts at $1.99 because it's also
starting at 256 gigs there's a lot more
details and interesting stuff about the
iPhone in that Hands-On video so you
know where to find that but then there's
the other stuff of this event also I
thought it would be cool to shoot here
since this is part of where they shot
some scenes in the keynote but now I'm
realizing that it's a real place there's
like chainsaws in the background so
sorry about the noise anyway uh we've
got apple watch stuff right so series 9
and Ultra 2 and one of the most
interesting things about these new
watches is that visually just looking at
them there's almost no way to actually
tell that you're looking at the new
watch it's very unlike Apple so I think
there's a new pink color with the series
9 but other than that looks identical to
the series 8 and the ultra 2 looks
identical to the ultra but instead under
the hood there's a big process update to
this new S9 system on a chip which is
more powerful and more efficient and
that's allowing to push the watches to a
higher Max brightness while keeping the
same coded battery life so the series 9
is going to get up to 2,000 nits Max
brightness now and the ultra 2 is up to
3,000 nits which is actually now it's
the brightest display ever on any Apple
product and they've also moved all Seri
requests on the watch now to stay on
device instead of always having to do a
round trip to the internet which I think
could help cuz there's a lot of
instances of Siri where you like ask it
what's the time in Cupertino and then it
like goes hold on a second wait for it
I'm thinking about it I don't know yet
and it's just frustrating and it doesn't
work so that should be faster and more
efficient it doesn't means Ser is going
to be good it just means it'll be bad
but faster but then there's also a new
Ultra wideband chip that can talk to the
iPhones to make find my iPhone way more
precise and actually point out a
direction to help you find your phone
instead of just playing a sound I think
that's going to be super useful for a
lot of people but the most sneaky
interesting update here to the watch is
this new double tap gesture so so okay
you've got the new watch on uh and
basically it's always able to detect if
you do this double tap of your thumb and
your index finger together and so I got
to try it a bunch of times at the event
with a demo watch in the Hands-On area
it actually seemed very accurate like
you basically you raise it to wake give
it a split second and then double tap to
press the primary button of whatever app
you're in that's on your screen at the
moment so it can accept or reject an
incoming phone call or stop a timer or
scroll through the smart stack of
widgets on the watch face and yeah it
was it was working really well for me
very quickly this would clearly be super
helpful if my other hand is busy or I'm
holding something or I just want to
quickly do something ordinarily honestly
i' would be trying to do that with my
nose so this is much better now the
reason I say this is sneaky is because I
don't know if you remember just a few
weeks ago or months ago this is the same
gesture used to select things while
you're wearing Apple VIs Pro in the VR
headset selecting things is like this
and so now on the watch selecting things
is like that now some of you have
already pointed out on Twitter this
isn't exactly new completely if you've
ever dug through the accessibility
settings on the Apple watch before
you've probably found by a slightly
different name basically the exact same
feature and you've been able to double
tap and do all kinds of other things now
why isn't this new double tap to select
primary stuff feature coming to other
Apple watches you might be asking Apple
says that basically this new S9 chip is
much faster at processing all the info
from All Those sensors and so you'll be
able to do it more readily and so that's
why it's only coming to the new S9
powered Apple
watches convenient but let's talk about
airpods real quick because this might
actually be the ultimate sneaky update
so the fact is these barely even got
mentioned during the keynote right like
they just casually dropped that there
would be a new USBC case for the airpods
Pro 2 in like one fleeting slide and
that was basically it so you could be
led to believe that there's just nothing
new with the airpods themselves and
they're exactly the same but you'd be
wrong so basically for all intents and
purposes airpods Pro 2 with the wireless
charging lightning case and airpods Pro
2 with the wireless charging USBC case
are the same product with a different
port unless you have apple Vision Pro in
which case the USBC version will be
capable of doing lossless audio with low
latency with this new codec that Apple's
created just for this purpose this
awesome immersive
experience so if you don't have apple
Vision Pro then they're basically the
same product with two different ports
but there is actually new hardware and
new architecture to make this feature
possible with the new USBC version I
don't think they want to talk about that
too much to not make people who just
bought them last week feel too bad about
it but they're actually different
headphones so that's a sneaky update
right there from Apple behind the scenes
on one of their most popular products
but that's a good transition just to get
to the the last seemingly big pillar of
this announcement which was carbon
neutrality and the environment so Apple
couldn't stop talking about the
environment throughout this keynote
including one huge overly self-
congratulatory like 10minute skit in the
middle of the keynote video with like
Tim Cook and Apple employees talking to
Mother Nature about how much progress
they've made with their products
environmentally I I I just basically
want to dig more into this later I would
say I'm not an expert on this so there's
no way that I can fully appreciate now
and fully understand now everything that
was said there's a lot of specific
language used some of it is very clear
like just straight up not using any
leather anymore in any Apple products uh
using recycled materials instead of new
virgin materials things like that having
more sustainable energy sources but then
there's other things that they I mean
there was a lot there was a lot going on
and some of it is not quite as simple
but they have clearly made a lot of
progress and change and they eventually
landed on this moment where they were
like the Apple watch is the first fully
carbon neutral product that Apple's
actually shipping on their way to
ideally being fully carbon neutral as a
company by 2030 and so there's a lot of
progress that they still need to make
and as much as we've talked about how
much Apple still needs to do I kind of
feel like I can't get mad at this like
you know what it feels like you ever see
those like YouTube videos where like a
YouTuber will on the street they'll be
miked up and they'll like give a
homeless person a 100 bucks or something
and like half the comments are like oh
you come on you clearly didn't have to
do it on camera like if you really cared
then you would do it not on camera and
that's probably all mostly true but also
that person in need still did just get a
100 bucks so it's like some net positive
was still done and this kind of feels
the same way to me like okay apple is
actually doing a bunch of stuff to use
recycled materials and to make less of
an impact on the environment and then
they're doing a big song and dance about
it so everyone can see it so that
everyone sees it and so you'd say okay
if they if they really cared they would
do a whole bunch more stuff and that's
still true but I can't get mad at the
improvements that they are actually
making hopefully that makes sense either
way like I said I'm not an expert I I
want to dig more into this I want to
talk to some people who actually are
experts on it who can help me out and
maybe that's a future topic for another
video but that's just my thoughts and
reactions from the Wonder lust event of
2023 let me know your thoughts are below
there's a lot to talk about and a lot of
random sneaky stuff and uh the comment
section is always open to talk about it
and Tech Timber rolls on so stick with
us subscribe if you haven't already
thanks for watching catch you guys later
[Music]
peace